I am actually a student in international economic relations.
I am 23 years old and I come from Poland.
I'm 74, I am a former teacher
and I come from Belgium.
I am a telecommunications retiree
I am 77 years old and I come from Cyprus
I am 19 years old and I live in Spain.
where I study at University.
We are four citizens from different nationalities
and we are here on a special mission.
This has been an intense experience
in the power of participatory democracy,
after months of discussions and powerful debates.
Today is Europe Day.
It marks the end of our work as citizens
on the Conference on the Future of Europe.
It's the moment where we deliver our conclusions
to the European institutions.
It's a very important event.
It's a huge democratic experiment.
This is a new process.
We are the first people to do it,
so it has been very difficult.
There is a lot of emotion,
because it is the result of many weeks' work.
We can't say it's over, but it is a big step.
Citizens from all 27 member states were randomly selected.
800 citizens in total.
It's an innovation, because besides these citizen panels,
there is a digital platform. So everyone can participate.
Their aim is to have a broad reflection
about the future of the European Union,
be it economic, political, social.
Then these ideas will be fine-tuned,
in order to then become
recommendations for politicians:
MPs, national ministers and so on.
When travelling through Europe I feel more European.
I like travelling a lot because I discover new cultures,
new ways of seeing the world.
Also, the people are very interesting.
I was selected in a totally random way.
I was very happy. I then explained it to my parents
and they told me it was probably a scam.
So, I wasn't really sure about coming,
but in the end, I came and I'm glad I did.
It was was very impressive,
arriving from a small country like Belgium
and meeting people from all the other European countries.
So, very quickly the Belgian dimension became a European dimension.
Of course I knew that I would keep my DNA and my Belgian identity,
but I instantly felt part of the group with all the others.
I had a proposal to join the working group
of economy, social justice and jobs.
And I thought: it's a brilliant opportunity
because I could tell them about young people's perspectives
and our economic position in the world.
This is for the translation, okay?
Thank you very much.
At the beginning, I made some proposals.
To improve democracy.
My dream for Europe concerns our children and grandchildren,
the young people of Europe.
I believe they will have a better future,
without employment-related problems,
without war and conflict between countries
This is what we expect from the EU.
I focused on anti-discrimination and security.
For me, the question of quality of life was important.
Our life should not depend only on work
it should rather be a good balance
between personal life and work.
In the first session, the citizens bring up fairly general things.
In the second session, they re-examine these main ideas and refine them
The third session consists of drafting orientations,
making recommendations that are much more concrete
and more likely to speak to decision-makers.
Because we are so different,
there were times when it was
very difficult for us to agree
and keep everybody happy.
But I think we've done an amazing job in our group.
What we are going to do this weekend:
We will have five orientations from our group.
The job of a facilitator as a neutral person
is to bring the citizens through this process.
To ensure that they are in this process
where they start from a very broad vision for the EU
to the specific recommendations.
It works with the help of the translators
who are remote, working online.
There's actually a pretty immediate translation, at most a few seconds' delay.
The floor is now to Mr. Kacper Parol, who is the spokesperson
of the citizens in the working group 'Economy'.
We had a lot of feedback for our proposals.
Some of the politicians didn't really agree
with some of the issues citizens mentioned.
Because they are learning too, about the Conference and the process.
So once they learned about the process, they were more appreciative.
Our panel 4 recommends a complete review of all agreements
and laws related to asylum and migration in Europe.
We've only got three years left
to reverse the greenhouse gas emissions trend,
not forgetting the water shortages ahead of us.
Climate action is now or never.
At the beginning, it was a little difficult
with the politicians,
who directed us like one directs
a meeting when one is in politics.
So we had fewer opportunities
to talk to each other.
So there, we had to reverse the trend a bit.
And it happened gradually,
and the end result is really what we expected:
to be able to speak out, to be listened to.
Our goal is for our voice, the voice of European citizens,
to be heard in the European Union.
This is what we will be asking for
from the competent European Union bodies tomorrow.
I think we now know that this sort of experience
of involving ordinary citizens in big debates about policy, it works!
And now we're seeing, in a multilingual environment
with simultaneous translation,
citizens from 27 member states of the European Union
discussing really complex issues
and coming forward with very important proposals.
So it's a good process, it should be used.
You have proven that this form of democracy works.
And I believe we should give it more room.
It should become part of the way we make policy.
So there's no time to waste.
Let's be loyal to the outcome of the conference.
Let's implement its conclusions as soon as possible,
because it's the will of the people
and let the will of the people prevail.
I feel that citizens should be more involved
in the day-to-day European Union work.
But I think that the Conference is also a great lesson
for our national governments.
We are very proud because all our efforts,
those of us who have been in the working groups,
are coming to an end and will now start to take shape
as they enter the phase of realisation.
For me, it was an extraordinary experience
because being called, at the age of seventy-four,
to talk about the future of Europe...
It was probably not for me that I came here,
but for my grandchildren.
I'm taking back with me the hope that Europe will be something...
That it will be a little more
what I want in the future when I am older.
I hope to be able to live in the Europe
we have imagined here.
The Conference on the future of Europe delivered 49 proposals
with more than 300 measures to improve the EU.
It is Europe's biggest ever experiment
in participatory democracy.
The members of the European Parliament are committed to ensuring
the Conference's vision of the EU of tomorrow becomes reality.